according to my watch I will just spent
over two hours announcing tons of new
software features and its developer
conference wait you didn't watch the
entire thing don't worry
here's everything you need to know
number one iOS 9 is coming this fall
with lots of new features and
improvements Siri is breaking out in a
big way she will become more context
aware and similar to Google now and
Microsoft's Cortana suggests information
when you need it other things I'm
excited about maps is finally getting
transit directions there's a new wallet
app which brings together Apple pay and
passbook and a new news app is coming to
the operating system number 2 iOS 9 is
going to turn the iPad into a real
computer this is the news I've been
waiting for the iPad will be getting a
new software keyboard the quick access
to shortcuts and it will even have a
trackpad there's also better support for
hardware keyboards but here's the big
one dual app view is coming but only to
the iPad air 2 unfortunately number
three El Capitan yes that's the name of
the new Mac software which adds a lot of
performance improvements but also new
features there's a new way to put apps
side by side similar to the iPad
improved mail features and better
spotlight search number for Apple music
is coming at the end of the month
Apple's music service will offer the
usual selection of songs and albums but
also a new beats 1 radio station curated
by real people it will be out for the
iPhone iPad Mac and PC on June 30th and
Android in the fall it will cost $10 a
month after the free three-month trial
number five the Apple watch is getting
new apps and other new stuff you'll
finally be able to customize the Apple
watch face with your own photos and
apples adding some other pretty lines
other small tweaks are coming too
you can respond to emails on the watch
add more friends and Siri will respond
to more commands apps will be better too
since they'll run right on the watch and
not on the phone